>>> A DISPUTE OVER LEGACY AND
LAND.
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW ON
HILTON ISLAND IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
HILTON HEAD ISLAND IN SOUTH
CAROLINA.
JOSEPHINE WRIGHT IS IN FRONT OF
A LAWSUIT AS DEVELOPMENT GOES UP
AROUND HER HOME.
SHE IS LITERALLY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THAT DEVELOPERS HOPE COULD BE
A NEW HOME COMMUNITY.
FOR WRIGHT, IT'S SO MUCH MORE.
D
DIANNE GALLAGHER REPORTS.
>>> OUR BLOOD IS CONNECTED TO
THESE TREES.
WE WILL KEEP THESE LANDS.
THIS LAND WILL BE HERE WITH US
IF IT'S GOING TO BE ANOTHER 200
YEARS.
THAT'S THE WAY WE LOOK AT IT.
>> Reporter: NOT EVERYONE HAS
THAT VIEW, THE MARSH AND BEACHES
OF HILTON HEAD ISLAND HAVE BEEN
HOME TO THEM SINCE AMERICA
BECAME AMERICA.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SAY
DEVELOPMENT THREATENS THOSE
FAMILIES WHO STILL CALL IT HOME.
>> WHY SHOULD WE GIVE UP SUCH A
PRECIOUS GIFT THAT GOD HAS GIVEN
US?
>> Reporter: JOSEPHINE WRIGHT
HAS LIVED IN THIS HOUSE FOR 30
YEARS BUT SHE SAYS HER FAMILY'S
HOME HAS BEEN ON THIS LAND SINCE
THE CIVIL WAR.
PURCHASED BY FRIEDMAN AND PASSED
DOWN BY GENERATIONS, HER HUSBAND
WANTED TO BE SURE TO KEEP THE
LAND IN THE FAMILY AFTER HIS
PASSING.
>> I FEEL SO MUCH PRIDE AND
COMFORT IN KNOWING THAT THIS IS
WHERE I WILL BE FOR THE REST OF
MY LIFE.
>> Reporter: BUT THE 93-YEAR-OLD
GREAT-GREAT-GRANDMOTHER HAS FELT
LITTLE COMFORT OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS.
>> THIS IS WHEN WE START HEARING
THE TREES, BOOM, BOOM.
>> Reporter: WRIGHT IS BEING
SUED BY A COMPANY WITH PLANS TO
BUILD 147 THREE-STORY TOWN HOMES
ALONG THIS JONESVILLE ROAD
COMMUNITY.
A HISTORIC NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> OUR BLOOD, SWEAT AND TEARS
ARE IN THIS LAND.
MY ANCESTORS ARE BURIED HERE
DOWN AT THE END OF THE ROAD.
>> Reporter: TODAY CONSTRUCTION
IS CLOSING IN AROUND WRIGHT'S
MODEST HOME.
HAS THE DEVELOPER AT ANY POINT
COME TO YOU TO SPEAK
FACE-TO-FACE ABOUT THIS?
>> NO.
I'VE NEVER SPOKEN TO ANY ONE OF
THEM.
THEY HAVE NEVER KNOCKED ON MY
DOOR.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS FIVE YEARS
AGO A WOMAN DID ASK HER TO
SELLING THE LAND TO AN
INTERESTED ANONYMOUS BUYER FOR
$39,000.
>> AND I SAID, YOU'RE INSULTING
MY INTELLIGENCE.
AND WOULD YOU GIVE THEM THAT
MESSAGE.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS HER FIRST
COMMUNICATION WITH THE COMPANY,
BAILEY POINT INVESTMENT LLC, WAS
SERVED LEGAL NOTICE WHICH
ALLEGES A SATELLITE DISH, A SHED
AND A PORTION OF WRIGHT'S
SCREENED-IN BACK PORCH ARE
SITTING OUTSIDE OF HER PROPERTY
LINE ENCROACHING ON THEIRS,
ACCORDING TO THEIR LAND SURVEY.
THE LAWSUIT SEEKS REMOVAL PLUS
JUST AN ADEQUATE COMPENSATION
FOR ITS LOSS OF THE USE AND
ENJOYMENT OF THEIR PROPERTY AND
EXPENSES RELATED TO DELAYS IN
DEVELOPMENT.
>> BAILEY POINT SAYS THE
CORNER --
>> THAT CORNER IS ON THEIR
PROPERTY.
>> Reporter: SO THE ISSUE IS
THAT CORNER?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: WRIGHT HAS FILED A
COUNTER SUIT ALLEGING BAILEY
POINT AND AFFILIATES ARE USING
HARASSMENT AND PRESSURE TACTICS
TO PRESSURE HER OFF THE LAND.
BAILEY POINT HAS FILED A
RESPONSE DENYING ANY HARASSMENT
AS WELL AS ANY PREVIOUS OFFERS
TO PURCHASE HER LAND.
SHE HAS RECEIVED AN OUTPOURING
OF SUPPORT IN DONATIONS EVEN
FROM CELEBRITIES LIKE TYLER
PERRY, SNOOP DOGG AND KYRIE
IRVING.
THE TOWN OF HILTON HEAD JUST
ANNOUNCED IT IS PAUSING ALL
CONSTRUCTION IN LINE WITH THEIR
TOWN CODE REFUSING TO ISSUE
BAILEY POINT BUILDING PERMITS
UNTIL THE LAWSUITS ARE RESOLVED.
BUT JOSEPHINE WRIGHT ISN'T ALONE
IF HER FIGHT.
>> SHE SPEAKS TO THE GULLAH
CULTURE AND DESIRE TO FIGHT BACK
.
>> Reporter: SELLERS RUNS A
NONPROFIT CALLED THE LOW COUNTRY
GULLAH FOUNDATION FIGHTING LAND
LOSS.
IT ESTIMATES SINCE HILTON HEAD
ISLAND BECAME A VACATION
DESTINATION AFTER MAINLAND
BRIDGE WAS BUILT IN THE 1950s,
THEY HAVE LOST NEARLY TWO-THIRDS
OF THEIR ACREAGE MOSTLY DUE TO
RISING PROPERTY TAXES AND
PROBLEMS WITH SOMETHING CALLED
HEIRS PROPERTY.
HOW PERVASIVE IS THAT ON THIS
ISLAND NOW?
>> IT'S PERVASIVE HERE BUT IT'S
PERVASIVE THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, HEIRS
PROPERTY IS THE PRIMARY WAY
BLACK PEOPLE IN AMERICA ARE
LOSING THEIR LAND.
>> Reporter: IT IS THE TYPE OF
LANDOWNERSHIP WHERE A SINGLE
PROPERTY MAY BE INHERITED BY
MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF A FAMILY FOR
GENERATIONS AFTER THE ORIGINAL
OWNER PASSES AWAY, BUT THERE'S
OFTEN A LACK OF CLEAR LEGAL
DOCUMENTATION MAKING FAMILIES
VULNERABLE TO LAND LOSS WHEN
THERE ARE DISAGREEMENTS WITH THE
FAMILY OVER SELLING.
IN CASES IT IS BEING PURCHASED
BY DEVELOPERS.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST PEACEFUL
AREAS.
>> Reporter: AND LOST BY THE
GULLAHS.
WRIGHT IS STANDING FIRM ON HER
GROUND.
>> LET ME PUT IT TO YOU THIS
WAY.
I'VE NEVER BACKED DOWN ON
ANYTHING THAT WAS RIGHT.
>> Reporter: NOW ON THE PAST
COUPLE MONTHS LEADING UP TO THIS
WEEK, CNN HAS REPEATEDLY REACHED
OUT TO BAILEY POINT INVESTMENT,
ANYONE THAT WE COULD FIND
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROJECT.
THEY TELL US THEY'RE NOT THE
DEVELOPER -- EXCUSE ME, THEY
TOLD ME THEY'RE NOT THE
DEVELOPER BUT AN INVESTMENT
COMPANY THAT FINANCED THE DEAL,
BUT WE REACHED OUT TO LAWYERS
FOR BAILEY POINT, WE'VE REACHED
OUT TO THE ARCHITECT, EVEN THE
ENGINEER FOR THE PROPOSED
SUBDIVISION.
NONE HAVE RESPONDED.
JOSEPHINE WRIGHT SAYS SHE PLANS
TO CONTINUE THIS FIGHT.
SHE WANTS HER 40 GRANDCHILDREN,
50 GREAT-GRANDCHILDREN AND 16,
SOON TO BE 17, BE
GREAT-GREAT-GRANDCHILDREN TO
ENJOY THAT PROPERTY UNTIL
THEY'RE 93 YEARS OLD.